bonjour nous sommes jeudi 25 juin merci
de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
de filippo votre magazine qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale
on commence à vite avec les titres de
cette édition et dans la qualité de
cette semaine les soldes d'été ont
commenté ce mercredi nous sommes allés
faire un tour dans les magasins pour
voir si les consommateurs étaient
toujours au rendez vous le campus du
crédit agricole organisé les 48 heures
technos qui parquent au programme
innovation hackaton & start up
nous y reviendrons enfin dans cette
émission nous vous proposons un dossier
innovation nous parlerons réalité
virtuelle et domotique deux secteurs qui
se développent nous avons rencontré les
acteurs locaux pour en savoir plus et
aussi cette semaine dans notre entretien
nous allons parler plan de déplacement
inter entreprises avec nous pour en
parler en plateau quatre invités jean
pierre schneider responsable
développement durable au sein de
l'entreprise
hilti bonsoir laurent legendre président
de l'association delta ce qui nous avons
également à monsieur derniers élus de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines et monsieur vega
directeur dé la mobilité de la casse qui
c'est bien ça
et bien messieurs nous allons parler
avec vous de la problématique du plomb
intérêt dès le déplacement
interentreprises dans quelques instants
mais avant cela passe en revue
l'actualité économique de la semaine
les soldes d'été c'est parti depuis ce
mercredi vous avez maintenant six
semaines pour chercher votre bonheur et
trouver peut-être de bonnes affaires
avec la suppression des soldes flottants
les consommateurs peuvent en profiter
une semaine de plus retour sur cette
première journée avec mélanie poker et
william l
les boutiques sont ouvertes depuis une
heure et des clients sont déjà là en
cette première journée
ça démarre en douceur même accompagné du
dernier né on fait des soldes pour un
billet mais la famille n'a pas le choix
voilà on l'a ouvert à 8h30 ce matin est
plutôt bien donc on a un bon ressenti
par rapport à une dernière c'est plutôt
bien donc revoir la saison relativement
terne mais les gens achètent cette année
encore c'est le portefeuille qui va
décider selon une étude 50 % des
français estiment que leur situation
économique s'est détériorée
ils viennent chercher le besoin je pense
aussi le coup de coeur qu'ils ont vu
quelque temps auparavant est
effectivement aussi les bonnes affaires
mais avant tout je pense qu'ils veulent
aussi se faire plaisir pour ma fille ça
sera dans l'est dans les 100 euros à peu
près c'est plus loin qu'avant
c'est moi c'est moi depuis quelques
temps oui parce que la vie est plus
difficile et que
voilà il ya beaucoup de frais il ya son
frère qui grandit aussi donc a besoin
aussi donc on restera un petit peu le
budget près de six français sur dix
prévoient de consacrer pour leurs achats
un panier moyen d'environ 245 euros et
70 % des consommateurs prévoit
d'attendre les 2ème et 3ème démarque six
mois c'est on entende direct du -30 -40
-50% il arrive
dès qu'ils trouvent quelque chose qui
leur plaît ils n'hésitent pas à prendre
cette année pas de soldes flottants la
période est rallongé d'une semaine les
bonnes affaires pourront se dénicher
jusqu'au mardi 4 août et un mode
innovation à présent mardi et mercredi
le crédit agricole organisé la seconde
édition des 48 heures techno du campus
ce ski parc à fond quand en yvelines
l'occasion de présenter les dernières
les dernières innovations les nouveautés
technologiques mais aussi de mettre en
avant des startups du territoire
regarder ce portage réalisé avec ama
jimenez parfois étonnantes l'innovation
et le thème de ces 48 heures techno de
sky parc à cette occasion partenaires
historiques et acteurs du secteur
bancaire était invité mais aussi de
jeunes startups présentes pour montrer
leurs nouveautés technologiques
parmi elles certaines viennent de 50 ans
new line comme lingua custodia créé
depuis quatre ans elle est active sur le
marché depuis neuf mois
ça nous permet de montrer ce qu'on sait
faire de dire qu'ils existent aussi à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des start-up
dans le domaine de la fim tech des
technologies appliquées au secteur
financier
et puis du coup on espère pouvoir aussi
prendre de bons contacts au frédéric
hall le campus accueille sur deux jours
différents acteurs du secteur bancaire
afin de montrer ses nouveautés
technologiques 1 à caton sur le thème de
l'innovation était organisé cet
événement rassemble des développeurs
réunis en équipes ils doivent élaborer
une application en 48 heures cette année
pour la première fois nous avons convié
des équipes d'informaticiens qui
travaille aussi sur ceux sur ce campus à
venir présenter leurs propres
innovations les innovations auxquelles y
pense pour servir les métiers de la
banque pour lesquels ils travaillent
votre objectif en rassemblant plein de
démonstrations autour de l'innovation
technologique
c'est de permettre à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs du groupe et surtout aux
informaticiens qui sont très présents
sur ce site et ce campus de saint
quentin en yvelines et vient de toucher
du doigt des innovations qui sont des
innovations qui pour certaines sont des
innovations domestiques des choses qu'on
pourra voir très vite dans nos maisons
et puis des innovations plus
technologies
près de 600 personnes ont participé à
cet événement au campus du crédit
agricole
il devrait être reconduit très
prochainement nous allons à présent par
les mobilités et pvi avec l'entretien
des semaines c'est tout de suite et nous
sommes donc en plateau avec mes quatre
invités vous êtes ici messieurs pour
parler des cinq ans de la mise en place
du pds sur l'agglomération de 50 ans
levin c'est un enjeu de taille
un colloque à d'ailleurs eu lieu cette
semaine aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet à fond quand on y viennent
ils rassemblent et donc la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines
les entreprises partenaires et également
les acteurs de ce déplacement domicile
travail avant d'en parler avec vous je
propose de regarder ce sujet réalisé
avec mélanie poker william l
c'est le bilan depuis cinq ans qui est
présenté ce matin cinq années pendant
lesquelles les salariés ont été incités
à délaisser leur voiture au profit
d'autres modes de transport
cinq ans j'aurais envie de dire une
centaine d'ateliers très réglée dans les
entreprises
d
amélioration de l'offre de bus on a
montré des augmentations de
fréquentation sur des lignes de bus vers
les zones d'activité de l'ordre de + 20
à +30 %
quand on écoute les besoins des salariés
c'est une cinquantaine de stands en
entreprise pour informer les salariés
des conditions de déplacement pour venir
sur les sites aujourd'hui 39 entreprises
font partie du dispositif sur saint
quentin en yvelines avec les secteurs
trappe elancourt le technocentre mais
rod et soul sangliers pis salou clé
saint-pierre et le secteur centre
nautique et guyancourt
cinquante mille personnes en bénéficient
pour renforcer les yeux ce sont
les habitudes qu'il faut avant tout
changer ils sont dans un réflexe
voitures qui se posent pas forcément la
question de faire autrement
non pas forcément la connaissance de
l'existence de toutes les alternatives
qui s'offrent à eux
il peut y avoir aussi des conditions qui
facilite
cet usage lassés par exemple sont du
stationnement facilement sur le lieu de
travail ça va forcément facilité le
visage de la voiture chaque entreprise
peut choisir son mode de déplacement le
crédit agricole dont les bureaux sont à
guyancourt favorise les modes doux et
notamment le vélo à assistance
électrique
les 2500 employés bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'une flotte de 10 vélos sur
les 3000 employés que compte le site
airbus dans la zone clé saint-pierre 15%
bénéficier des améliorations apportées
sur plusieurs lignes de bus dont trois
principales nous on privilégie
essentiellement l'offre de bus de
proposer par la casse qui on veut pas de
mettre deux navettes propre parce que
justement on n'a pas la capacité non
plus de fournir le nombre d'usagers dont
on a beau me permettre de rentabiliser
une offre de navette le salarié viennent
d'un peu partout sont passés mobile donc
on privilégier au maximum le travail
avec la communauté d'agglomération et
par-delà avec le stif pour développer
faciliter les transports collectifs
existants d'autres projets sont en cours
de réflexion pour réduire les heures de
transport ou favoriser le rapprochement
habitat travail
alors nous voulons de regarder à ce
sujet j'ai tout d'abord envie de vous
poser une question à vous monsieur
legendre
voilà ce que pour nous le rappeler me
rappeler un petit peu c'est le résumé
c'est qu'on prions que vous avez tiré au
bout de cinq ans permet ce que c'est
plutôt positif
oui c'est très positif 52 p des yeux
c'est une véritable expérience qui a une
maturité qui s'est développé des
véritables conditions d'un travail en
collaboration entre les acteurs publics
paix comité d'agglomération avec la
direction la mobilité la chambre de
commerce et les entreprises avec un
dispositif vertueux qui permet d'obtenir
des améliorations progressives d'année
en année maintenant il reste encore des
choses à faire a toujours en gros 15 %
de nos utilisateurs qui utilisent les
transports en commun on a un taux de
progression qui est de l'ordre un peu
moins d'un pour cent par an
donc tout ça est quand même relativement
lent et il faut trouver des solutions
innovantes pour accélérer mais
surveillés quels ont été les mêmes les
plus compliqués peut être à mettre en
place les éléments les plus compliqués
on était peut-être tout ce qui concerne
l'offre ferroviaire sur l'offre
ferroviaire c'est vrai que on peut dire
qu'on a eu un bilan très positif sur la
mobilisation des deux entreprises qui a
été une vraie surprise puisque ça on a
une vraie dynamique et d'ailleurs ce qui
remarquable ans colocks finalement la
mobilité est porté par les entreprises
du territoire aujourd'hui c'est un vrai
discours fort des entreprises du
territoire qui véhicule une image
positive du territoire sur l'offre aux
bulls effectivement on a un vrai levier
au niveau de l'agglomération donc à
partir de là on a pu ajuster l'offre aux
besoins
par contre sur l'offre ferroviaire c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des cadencements qu'on
était comme très compliqué on a eu du
mal avec le stif et la sncf à être
entendu mais c'est vrai que l'année
dernière on a eu pour la première fois
une évolution positive avec une heure de
pointe qui a été élargie sur la ligne où
c'est à dire la ligne la verrière la
défense jean-pierre choisir vous occupez
justement du développement durable chez
hilti voilà les ça a été compliqué aussi
au niveau des entreprises de mettre ça
en place peut être au niveau de la
maturation des employés leur faire
comprendre que le covoiturage sinon
c'était une bonne idée oui c'était pas
très facile parce qu'il fallait
mobiliser l'ensemble des employés là
également leur montrer tout le bénéfice
qu'ils pouvaient en tirer
et puis surtout il faut continuer là
dedans parce que c'est pas simplement en
parlant un peu pendant une année de ces
moyens de transport alternatifs que on
arrive à les mettre en place
ça prend du temps il faut changer les
habitudes et donc il faut continuer à
mobiliser les employés autour des
différents types de déplacements pas
seulement le covoiturage parce que le
covoiturage en est à intéressant mais il
y aussi les transports en commun voire
les modes doux de déplacement comme le
vélo électrique pour rebondir sur le
continuer je pense que ça c'est un
élément très fort le continuer puisque
il ya eu beaucoup de mouvement
entre effectivement quand on a commencé
maintenant j'ai eu beaucoup de rotations
c'est à dire les référents gauger dans
les entreprises ça bouge et ça bougeait
beaucoup à la chambre de commerce
ça bougeait beaucoup à la caisse qui est
la dynamique du lieu ne s'est pas
essoufflé et s'est même renforcé
donc ça prouve que finalement
effectivement on a eu des résultats
positifs et c'est dynamique est lancée
et le mouvement et fort je pense c'est
vrai je voyais réagir justement la
communication c'est important aussi haut
niveau la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie vous avez agi pour une
nouvelle entreprise est à dire que le
rhône la chambre de commerce est dans
son rôle
un peu régalien qui est d'être un
animateur du développement économique où
il a un rôle particulier à jouer
le yeux pour nous a été l'occasion au
niveau de saint quentin de participer
avec delta de favoriser la création
delta d'aidé delta devenir une seule une
association qui intègre correction en
même temps qui est l'association en fête
des associations du département des
yvelines pour les entreprises et nous
sommes la chambre de commerce sur
plusieurs paix dès que nous en aurons
fait signer ces derniers temps notre
volonté est de mettre du lien dans les
entreprises et je pense que delta est la
preuve qu'il est possible de mettre du
lien qu'ils entreraient se parlent entre
elles ce qui va nous permettre de
développer d'autres opérations lance en
ce moment open innove où je pense
qu'avec delta sur open innove on aura
encore un gros travail de collaboration
ave a justement la communication c'est
un grosse un grand enjeu
oui la communication c'est le nerf de la
guerre il faut et dpd yeux à différents
niveaux
il ya la communication avec les gens qui
sont censés organiser le dispositif et
quand on est en seconde couronne
parisienne s'est pas forcément facile je
de paris on existe on a du mal à exister
donc ça c'est un point important et donc
si on veut obtenir des choses
c'est pour ça qu'on a créé cette
association il ya un lobbying a organisé
et c'est un point très important et puis
la communication comme je disais jean
pierre qui doit être quotidienne auprès
des salariés récurrentes et et qui doit
être structurée pour permettre
d'informer et de faire en sorte que le
dispositif fonctionne et qu'il se
développe pour les entreprises un
vestiaire là des bénéfices a peut être
méconnu est ce que ça permet voilà
d'attirer de jeunes recrues par exemple
je pense que tu avoues oui balle le fait
d'avoir un territoire attractif au
niveau des déplacements les déplacements
soit facile permet justement de faire
venir des talents et d'en faire
bénéficier les entreprises innovantes de
saint quentin
on a quand même des entreprises
aéronautiques des entreprises des
banques des téléphonies et donc ce sont
toutes des entreprises qui sont
innovantes au niveau de leur service et
il est important de continuer de pouvoir
attirer des jeunes talents dans
l'entreprise et donc c'est ses moyens
les moyens de mobilité mis en place
permettent justement de répondre à leur
demande donc cinq ans un premier bilan
qui est même plutôt positif qu'est ce
qu'il reste à faire maintenant quels
sont les grands enjeux auxquels vous
avez travaillé pour améliorer à 7 et des
yeux je pense que il reste encore
beaucoup à faire parce que finalement on
se rend compte que sur ce travail de
l'ouvragé toujours à reprendre toujours
art of mettre sur la table puisque
finalement pour qu'une offre de
transports en commun reste de
performance sur tout ce qui arrive dans
le dos numériques étant tous qui tout ce
qui se produit finalement dans le
domaine des déplacements
on voit qu'il y a nécessité d'être
systématiquement l écoute de l'usaj et
des besoins et ses usagers ces besoins
sont plus en plus fluctuant son
effectivement comment dire culture à
partir de là c'est par l' écoute écoute
et l'adaptation à ces besoins permanents
que finalement l'offre reste performante
à défaut effectivement on restera en
deviendra moins attractif il ya aussi un
point important qui est l'innovation
moi je crois beaucoup aux d'innovation
d'usagé on a travaillé sur certains
sujets avec des start up qui nous
apporter des solutions innovantes
le covoiturage dynamique un truc dont on
n'avait pas entendu parler c'est une
start up qui nous en a parlé qui me l'a
présenté on a expérimenté sur un pda et
ça marche ça répond besoin on avait
essayé avec du covoiturage classique
type blabla car ça ne marchait pas donc
ça c'est très important et puis il va
falloir qu'on fasse rentrer de nouveaux
acteurs on a des universitaires des
chercheurs sur ce territoire
il faut absolument qu'on a suscité leur
créativité et qu'ils nous apportent eux
aussi de nouvelles idées pour progresser
et trouver justement les solutions qui
répondent à ce besoin de fluctuation que
citer mm
eh bien merci beaucoup monsieur d'être
venu à se mettre au plateau pour
répondre à nos questions ce sera donc le
mot de la fin je vous propose maintenant
de continuer très mission avec le
chiffre de l'ensemble
et notre chiffre la semaine il concerne
le chômage 1,4 pour cent c'est la hausse
du chômage dans les yvelines au mois de
mai il a continué sa progression on
compte 870 demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires en catégorie a sur le
département le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi de catégorie a est à présent de
60 points 1690 personnes les hommes de
moins de 25 ans représentent la
catégorie la plus touchée
toutes catégories le nombre de chômeurs
en mai divine et 2,89 1920 pour
information en ile de france
l'augmentation est de 1,2 pour cent en
mai pour les demandeurs d'emploi en
catégorie a et sur un an le chômage a
progressé de 7,1 pour cent dans les
yvelines pour les trois catégories
rassembler je vous propose maintenant de
regarder avec nos le dossier la semaine
et nous proposons dans cette édition une
un dossier innovation donc en deux
volets le premier volet c'est la réalité
virtuelle
cette simulation de réalité est en
pleine ascension nous avons rencontré
deux entreprises saint-quentinoise qui
sont dans ce domaine et nous ont parlé
de ce développement
regardez ces images de patrick jacques
de dixmude romain respini pour le
montage visiter un appartement comme si
vous y étiez c'est la promesse de la
réalité virtuelle réalisé grâce à un
ordinateur et des logiciels
elle permet de vivre une expérience
visuelle et sonore dans un monde
artificiel créé numériquement
ici on propose un système immersif à
tarifs très attractifs pour les pme on
va projeter les images 3d sur les murs
et l'utilisateur aura besoin de porter
finalement qu'une paire de lunettes 3d
toute simple ce les mêmes qu'hier au
cinéma il va pouvoir directement
interagir dans le système la réalité
virtuelle ce n'est pas que pour les jeux
vidéo si l'entreprise d'emmanuel vend
son système à des salles de jeu ce n'est
pas sa seule cible clientèle
architecture immobiliers de plus en plus
de secteurs sont en demande et vos
l'utilité de cette nouvelle technologie
des savates ans en plus de juste à voir
les murs on va avoir les schémas des
câblages électricité les évacuations
on va pouvoir voir d'emblée déjà dans la
conception un certain nombre de défauts
la partie immersive
elle rajoute la spec perceptif je me
mettre dans une pièce est ce que les
volumes sont cohérents par rapport à ce
qu'on avait imaginé son papier est ce
qu'on va avoir d'autres défauts de
conception vraiment dynamique en
cinématique typiquement nouveau une
porte à ce qu'on va pas connu quelque
chose qu'on n'aurait pas vu sur un
ordinateur un écran plat emmanuel van un
système dit low cost compter au minimum
dix mille euros pour être accessible aux
pme c'est dix fois moins onéreux que les
grands murs d'image utilisés par les
groupes industriels ici typiquement on
peut commencer à faire du home staging
échanges et les matériaux de certains
éléments
que ce soit les tapis on peut aller un
petit peu plus loin changer et couleur
des rideaux
on voit là ça c'est ce genre
d'applications pour l'immobilier
qui as
un gros à venir en fait pour le secteur
industriel créé en 2014
la société a bénéficié d'un coup de
pouce de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
elle lui prêtant leur image ultra
performant pour améliorer ses logiciels
cette technologie intéresse aussi le
monde scientifique et universitaire au
pit la plateforme d'intégration et de
test les chercheurs l'utilisent pour la
modélisation 3d des plasmas et des
champs magnétiques
ces chercheurs ils vont céder 2 chômage
qui grâce aux lunettes de stéréoscopie
qui permettent d'avoir un vendu immersif
vraiment plus important que sur un écran
d'ordinateur simple c'est de cette
immersion on va vraiment permettre de
mieux se rendre compte des différents
champs pour skill de ce film de la
physique des plasmas la réalité
virtuelle déjà bien connu des
scientifiques et groupes industriels se
démocratise grâce à ce masque l'oculus
rift autres moyens plus connus pour
profiter de cette immersion numérique
est déjà utilisé par deux cent mille
personnes dans le monde pour les jeux
vidéo c'est le système qui a choisi en
plissant une start-up locale on
développe des interfaces qui permet de
se déplacer physiquement dans toutes les
directions tout en restant sur place
donc ça sous couple avec un casque type
immersif on met le cas ce soir yeux et
ça permet de se déplacer à l'infini
la société présente son produit aux 48
heures techno du crédit agricole
une façon d'augmenter sa visibilité et
de perfectionner son système en le
faisant tester son nouveau et premier
produit permet de se déplacer
physiquement dans le monde virtuel grâce
à un tapis roulant pris trente mille
euros
les plombs sont conçus à voisins le
bretonneux c'est ici que travaillent les
ingénieurs
la start up créée il ya cinq ans a déjà
collaboré avec de grands groupes comme
airbus immobiliers représente également
pour elle un secteur porteur car chaque
année les erreurs de chantier revienne à
plus de 10 milliards d'euros
mais pour eric bellon les champs
d'application de la réalité virtuelle
sont encore plus large s'agit dans tous
les domaines dans sur l'information ce
faire vous déplacer former des équipes
au sol pour intervenir dans une passion
pétrolière ça donne grave ont du sens
c'est à dire qu'il il se forme il se met
une amie dans cet avant il la connaît
par coeur quant à elle sur site qui sera
opérationnel la commercialisation de gaz
qu'en fin d'année 2015 devrait doper le
secteur surtout auprès du grand public
selon l'institut d'études britannique à
0 le montant du marché de la réalité
virtuelle devrait dépasser les 5
milliards de dollars d'ici 2018 et
deuxième volet de notre dossier
innovation c'est la domotique et la
domotique ses longs sont des
technologies électroniques informatiques
et du bâtiment qui permettent de
centraliser les différents systèmes de
la maison ou d'une entreprise de plus en
plus de particuliers ou de
professionnels se laisse tenter nous
sommes allés voir ce qu'il en était dans
les yvelines
patrick jacques de dixmude et romain
brusc année pour le montage la domotique
une technologie avant tout discrète
à première vue rien ne distingue cette
maison d'une autre et pourtant souvent
on dit qu'c'est c'est un petit peu
compliqué la domotique mais l'or avec
avec les photos on voit tout de suite la
façon de fonctionner
réglez la lumière le chauffage ou les
volets en un clic c'est le principe de
la domotique
sébastien beaudoin est électricien et
travaille entre trappe et joueurs pour
chartrain il a entièrement équipée cette
maison domotique en trois semaines
seulement
les propriétaires peuvent ainsi tout
contrôle et de la lumière ou volé en
passant par le chauffage ou encore
alarme
mais ce confort a un prix oui un coup ça
serait mentir
le coup on peut le récupérer avec
les économies qu'on peut faire ça varie
entre 2 % à 10 % de la construction là
si on est sur une maison de 200 mille
euros
on va être entre 4000 euros à 20000
les alarmes et les détecteurs sont les
équipements les plus souvent installés
ils représentent 32 % du marché de la
domotique 60% des installations sont
destinés au marché haut de gamme dans
des résidences de standing
le marché a progressé de 18 % entre 2008
et 2010 les perspectives d'évolution
sont nombreuses
fattouche les professionnels les
particules et tertiaire c'est très vaste
c'est en plus de ça on va se dire j'ai
de plus en plus avec le grenelle de
l'environnement
la rt 2012 on nous demande déjà de
mettre de la domotique juste pour
surveiller notre consommation
on est on a un premier stade de
domination au niveau de la nappe on voit
l'état actuel du radiateur donc
économique et donc on a juste à faire
une petite impulsion et plus doit pour
pour le soulever ou le décembre dès
l'instant que le pied bonhomme elle
sourit ça veut dire que l'information et
la partie l'entreprise de sébastien à 7
ans en 2013 il a multiplié par trois son
chiffre d'affaires le secteur est
porteur c'est l'analyse que fait michel
gareau fort d'une expérience de 25 ans
il a vu évoluer la domotique
si son potentiel est connue depuis les
années 70 c'est aujourd'hui qu'ils
commencent à se réaliser
l' avantage maintenant c'est que il ya
des solutions qui se banalise qui se
démocratise et puis surtout il ya un
point qui est extraordinaire c'est que
il ya un outil qui est l'outil
maintenant fantastique qui fait ou qui
est le smartphone et ça c'est la
révolution dans le milieu de la
domotique
si actuellement l'installation de la
domotique ne représente que 2% de son
chiffre d'affaires et reste encore
coûteuse la donne pourrait bientôt
changer le prix des composants et plus
accessible et la demande des
consommateurs évoluent les yvelines
c'est un département riche avec des
possibilités de gens qui vont avoir
besoin de confort d'assistance dead et
qui veulent des solutions simples donc
on a cette première cible clientèle qui
est cette personne là le deuxième aspect
je disais les personnes ont des
populations vieillissantes
il ya dans le département des yvelines
une population vieillissante haussier
qui va qui répond au double critère
critères de richesse et puis critères de
vieillissement
donc on a cette cible
et puis on a une troisième cible et je
pense que ces outils là comme le
smartphone est bien vont permettre à des
gens en situation de handicap de pouvoir
gagner en autonomie
aujourd'hui la domotique en france
avoisine les 150 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires la france représente
10% du marché européen
un marché encore confidentiel qui
devrait devenir en 2015 un marché de
masse c'est bientôt la fin de notre
émission mais avant de nous quitter je
vous propose de découvrir avec -
l'agenda la semaine le travail en temps
partagé une autre façon de recruter
aussi notre façon de travailler c'est
une thématique qui vous intéresse sachez
que le mardi 30 juin de 10h à 12h la
cité des métiers organise une réunion
d'information sur ce sujet il faut
s'inscrire également auprès de la cité
des métiers pour y participer
enfin le mercredi 1er juillet à 17h30
business net le club d'entrepreneurs
organise une soirée expertises et
talents avec douze ateliers interactifs
au blue office de montigny le bretonneux
animée par deux entrepreneurs
différentes thématiques liées au monde
de l'entrepreneuriat seront abordés plus
d'informations sur le site business
tirer net.fr c'est maintenant la fin de
notre émission je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée et vous donne rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour un prochain
numéro de fil échos